en russie à présent le forum économique
oriental s'ouvre aujourd'hui à
vladivostok et ce pour trois jours alors
de quoi s'agit-il nous retrouvons tout
de suite notre correspondante verhaeghe
hoffman
[Musique]
bonjour verra alors qu'attendre de cette
première journée au forum économique
orientale
bonjour olivier le de 4000 participants
de 58 ans ont confirmé leur présence au
forum économique orientale à vladivostok
il ouvre c'est ce nouveau rendez-vous du
monde des affaires s'ouvre aujourd'hui à
vladivostok en extrême orient aux revues
sait s'il s'agit du 8 heures de décalage
horaire donc il est déjà ici 16 heures
cette année le forum se concentre
surtout sur de nouvelles opportunités
pour l'extrême-orient dans un monde en
mutation dans son message aux
participants l'événement le président
russe l'a dit mr poutine a affirmé qu'il
était prévu de discuter de mise en
valeur du potentiel de l'extrême orient
russe et de l'amélioration du climat
d'investissement
je vous propose d'écouter
le thème du forum de cette année de
nouvelles opportunités pour l'extrême
orient dans un monde en mutation suppose
des discussions approfondies sur les
perspectives de mise en valeur du
potentiel énorme et véritablement unique
dont dispose l'extrême orient par
conséquent dans le cadre du forum
économique orientale 2021 il est prévu
de définir les formes les mécanismes
d'interaction optimaux visant à
améliorer le climat d'investissement à
développer les infrastructures de
transport énergétique industrielle et
touristique ainsi qu'à assurer un niveau
élevé de sécurité environnementale la
russie a décidé d'annuler son forum
économique orientale en septembre
dernier à cause de la pandémie de
coronavirus cette annexe le forum se
tient malgré le contexte ça me faire un
peu tendue à tous les participants sans
exception y compris les journalistes ont
par exemple dû présenter un test pcr
négatifs afin d'activer leur badge
d'entrée merci beaucoup et on verra pour
toutes ces précisions un forum
économique de la nive au stock que vous
suivez pour nous sur rt france
[Musique]